my view is to start but then of course
council master wouldn't bear to take
part in the first item
you
you
for planning application number DC 1904
796 land opposite Broadmeadow Washington
law will heirs as set out in our papers
over to you Alex okay thank a chairman
sorry I got that wrong
over drums going to introduce it
thoughts I'm sorry rehearsed no I was
just gonna say something just to begin
with I'm not sure how much awareness
members may have on this type of
applications so this application
pacifically
is a section 73 application this is a
type of application that that allows you
to vary a previous application that's
been approved so in this case we already
got the outline permission granted for
the erection of up to 22 houses and that
was obviously granted with a number of
conditions this application it is not
another application this application is
linked to that host application if you
like what is seeking to do is very to
conditions of that previous application
it's sometimes called a minor amendment
application there are Pacific rules
which I'm not going to go into to apply
to when you can make this type of
application
but essentially what we're dealing with
here is just the Pacific's of those
conditions that it refers to to be
varied and Alex will go through that in
more detail just to make sure that
people are aware from the offset that
there is a general difference of what
they're dealing with as opposed to
dealing with an entire fresh application
and everything so just be clear we're
not going to go through the whole thing
this is purely two Amendment items we
all live in Austin essentially you're
looking at the amendment to what is
already been approved thank you over to
onyx thank you
yes I has been set out there thank you
to the area manager for doing that this
is a section 73 application to vary
conditions specifically conditions 21
and 27 relating to ecology and
specifically bats
of existing planning permission existing
outline planning permission for
application reference DC 1702 783 which
was approved for up to 22 dwellings on
land at Broadmeadow Worsham lullo's
essentially the proposal relates as I
said to bats and the proposed extension
of the amount of existing tree belt to
be protected which look lies to the
north and east of the site the area of
tree belt to be protected is proposed to
be extended from 70 metres as previously
proposed and approved to 340 meters
giving an increase of 700 sock moment
partners 270 metres an additional 270
metres and the proposal is also for the
reduction in the width of the under
undeveloped buffer zone along the the
northern edge of the the site boundary
only and I'll have a slide to hopefully
detail that a bit better for you so
we're looking for a reduction from 50
metres to 5 metres
now the benefits of this are for what
what back activity we have there at the
moment
and this has all been put to and
considered and approved by our
ecological consultants at place services
and it's it's more of a bat foraging
area as I understand for for male bats
rather than a roost and it's not with
the 5 meter is more appropriate to that
5 meter an extension and in addition to
that the existing conditions with
regarding protective fencing to ensure
the buffer and a sensitive lighting
scheme alongside that so there's lots of
conditions at all linked in together for
the benefits of bats and that's really
where what we're trying to improve by
where this applications
go through some slides again the general
location of the the village within the
district's general location of the sites
this is an aerial view so to the north
edge of or some of the willows here we
are again
so the first plan so in red here is the
application site plan for the 22
dwellings and here is the tree
protection zone originally approved and
this is the proposed extension now
within the site itself here what was
previously approved was 15 meters we're
now proposing to reduce that down to 5
meters for the for the reasons as set
out in the report and we'll clarify that
as we go through the presentation for
you this is that same plan but with an
aerial view instead of a drawing
constraints map you can take from this
really but clearly this is a key sight
which is important to two bats and
ecology which we're looking to protect
so therefore setting that out verbally
for you so it's an application to very
conditions 21 and 27 of the initial
reference the existing conditions
inconsistent as they required a buffer
zone decided to protect that habitat at
differing widths 50 meters and 10 meters
further ecological studies suggest that
the the off the pake as it were with no
real ecological reasoning behind it 15
meter buffer zone is neither the most
effective measure for the protection of
bat population nor does it offer the
optimum enhancement opportunity in
relation to the bat habitat in the area
so we're looking to improve that the
application proposes to vary the logical
conditions again attached to that that's
I'm permission from 50 meters to 5
meters with the addition of the
protected anti light spill fence or
dense hedge and that will secure the
extension to the protected tree line as
as I've mentioned before the proposals
are considered to provide best spoke
ecological enhancements in relation to
the bat population and beyond the
proposals provide further mitigation and
a husband beyond that proposed with the
original host application with greater
ecological benefits so that's what we're
really seeking to achieve here this is
an extract from the ecological report
provided by the applicant and is a more
detailed plan for you which shows the
existent existing area of protection in
orange with the proposed extension in
red and within the site that extended at
the 15 meters previously that's proposed
to be reduced to 5 and I just felt that
and allows for a better character and
layout when we come to was a matter
stage for the location and orientation
of the houses etc and onto some
photographs that is the existing
adjacent housing estate that Broadmeadow
and
looking there towards the north and this
is in the distance here existing tree
line which we're looking to protect and
that will extend away right into the
country side of the page there to the
right and this is the the corner of the
site looking back from brought meadow
and up to the north and as you're coming
down waters field road here this is the
mill effect of a site the trees we're
looking to protect and then a five meter
buffer zone which is approximately in
the location of this existing track
which gives access to farmland at the
moment this is the existing tree belt
which has a footpath in to woven in it
so yes all all the enhancements proposed
for that to give it greater protection
and that's as it continues off again
designated public right-of-way along the
other side of what's field Road to the
north of the village a conclusive
presentation for the reasons given in
the report officer recommendation is for
approval thank you thank you do we have
some questions yes ma'am
just a really quick one you just show
two photos from I had a footpath in it
which I thought was the other side of
the road and then the other one was
Sisters of a track so can you just say
which which where they're looking you
know I'm saying
especially the last two
of the site this is the yeah I
understand that it was it was the last
he like I say one literally had a
footpath in the mid in the midst of the
tree oh I see right okay the frame side
is the side what is that the opposite
side there right this one is the same
title that as a site I didn't see I
didn't think there was a footpath there
that's farmers confused yes it's
interwoven with with the trees hey I
haven't came yes whether it's a formal
footpath or not but it's certainly
certainly there sir am i a permissive
Department okay
thank you okay does the protection zone
cover all those trees as well or are
they all do for removal okay go back sit
with him
so so what all these trees here
referring to well the five meters would
be beyond that so these would all be
protected and then the five meter buffer
zone would be beyond that approximately
where the track is if you can see that
that area green bud there yeah so it's
the tree belt plus five yes okay any
other question yeah kasa go through just
a question why was it 15 meters earlier
that would have been quite wide wouldn't
it yes indeed that was a sort of off the
peg with no real Rika logical reasoning
behind it when when the when the
permission was originally granted by
committee it was like all we'll give it
give it 15 meters so yeah there's
committees there
yeah yeah cancer field it's already come
back yeah I thought it was something
about one width is appropriate for bats
where they're breeding and the other one
is to where they are empty door was only
use it but just brief question the I
noticed the density of housing on this
site quite high I wonder what this
change of sort of 10 meters does that
reduce it all the figures in the in the
papers as it
yeah as it was gonna be or as he is
gonna be okay um well the application
when it was approved was really just a
red line on a plan there was no
indicative layouts proposed but this
certainly would give us the opportunity
to provide a less dense and more
characterful black when it comes to that
yeah okay thank you
no one knows another question so we'll
move on no one from the parish counts
from no objects and their supporter but
we do have the agent Susanna's son
Sandlin please come forward thank you
for waiting so long this morning
and again three minutes please
ish sorry okay
this application and as we've seen seeks
to amend to conditions on the outline
planning permission granted in 2018 for
the erection of 22 homes the application
before you does not reconsider the
decision and as you've heard it's a
bespoke the application proposes a
bespoke fact habitat mitigation measure
and offers significant enhancements to
the local wildlife by extending the tree
belt
a further 340 meters beyond its existing
length the original condition included a
15 meter buffer zone adjacent to the
hedge as a bat mitigation measure and it
was put forward by the ecological
consultant at the time as a sort of off
the peg mitigation measure and this
would have been appropriate for a bat
roost but as you've heard there is no
batteries at this site and in this
instance a better protection is to offer
a longer line for them the migrating
bats and hunting bats to fly along lone
male bats require a long sheltered
commuting route to enable them to fly
longer distances at the application site
there was just a relatively short tree
belt and beyond this the fact the bats
have to fly unprotected over open fields
this bespoke ecological enhancement puts
forward an extension to the tree belt
and reduces the width of the buffer zone
by reducing the width of the buffer zone
there is the benefit of bringing forward
a lower dead low density and better
quality housing development in the long
term and the council psychological
consultant and the planning officer have
have supported this and we welcome this
as a major economic edge ecological
benefit the application also seeks to
amend condition 27 which requires the
submission of an ecological mitigation
and management plan we have now
submitted this in full and placed
services your ecological consultants
have been consulted on it as such we
asked the committee to allow the revised
wording of condition 27 to simply
require compliance with this plan rather
than a lay
submission to be approved in writing the
council psychological consultants and
your planning officer have recommended
the approval of this scheme so now there
is no need to discharge this at a later
date we welcome your office's
recommendation to amend condition 21 as
worded in the committee papers and 27 as
verbally reported this afternoon we hope
that the members will accept this
recommendation and that you will support
this bespoke ecological enhancement by
offering your support to the
applications afternoon questions I got
you and can you tell me should this be
granted when any building will commence
should this be granted when will the
building commence well you will still be
tied by the original planning it at the
dates on the original planning
application which I think this is there
another year to go one more year for
reserve matches exactly and say yeah it
would be after that any other questions
councillor feel probably a bit out of
order but the lighting scheme 22
somewhere in the papers it talked about
EMM P as a lie and I have no idea what
that is you could enlighten me and yes
so that was the what was talked about in
condition 27 there was a requirement to
submit an ecological management
mitigation management plan and so that's
what that is is it's a report that we've
already submitted to pick up on that
because one of the original
recommendations the condition says that
the lighting and design scheme prior to
occupation now I've seen it happen on
another site where they were bats but
we've then allowed them to put in street
lights that are on a PIR that the
daughter does saying so one of those
infrared things that flesh when you've
walked past them
we've allowed them to use a dawn to dusk
setting on that so with one condition
we're saying you've got to comply with
this but them in another condition we
always hit as a lighting design scheme
prior to application can I be assured
that the lighting scheme
we approve we'll tie in with the
ecological mitigation collage achill
mitigation plan does include
restrictions on lighting close to that
buffer zone and I would say a fence
between the buffer zone and the the
development say that you know there's
increased protection and you know cats
it sort of kept our probably to the
officers actually given we've just
approved houses across the other side of
the road to this today
have we not does the same ecological
mitigation have to happen there that's
happening here or do bats not cross the
road there were conditions in terms of
the ecology on that other site so there
is a consistency between both of these
sites and as I was around at the time
when they were originally approved
didn't get did that that was all part of
the discussion okay any other questions
Castlefield okay thank you very much
thank you we don't have anything from
the board member members so so we just
discussed debate and come to conclusion
Casa Gosselin counselor field um well
I'm quite happy to recommend the
proposal build on that basis all set a
bit I'm sure with a bat spoke to me or
someone else but there seems to be a
good thing to be doing
does anyone would debate this all go
straight to a vote straight to the vote
I guess all those who favor the
recommendation as laid out in page two
eight eight and two eight nine of our
papers share pounds please that's
unanimous thank you very much
okay the final item today DC 1804 nine
five the bypass nurses Braun padrone
Brantford which is on page 423 of our
papers
thank you so this is a reserved matters
application for 2012 so the reserved
matters are appearance and landscape
layout and scale only access was agreed
at outline stage you will note on your
table two papers relate papers that
there were comments from the Parish
Council which relates the access but as
I've stated it that was already agreed
at outline stage and can't be really
visited you'll also note within the
report that there are comments from the
flood officer however the details of the
surface water drainage are a condition
of the outline so not something that is
particularly concerned with in this
application apart from where it relates
to me out at the layout so those are the
key planning issues so this is the site
you will notice that there are quite a
few biodiversity indicators on that site
they were dealt with at the outline
where there are ecological mitigation
and particularly mitigation for the
reptiles which is what a lot of these
show you'll also notice that there's a
public right-of-way along here and this
is the railway again this is the aerial
photograph this is the neighbor here
that's mentioned within the report and
then the other nadir is sort of within
the site it's nurseries cottage it's
located here and that's to be retained
and then you'll see that there were
other buildings within the site it's an
old nursery and some stonemasons yard so
there are various derelict buildings and
hard standing within the site again
further area of view you can see that
the site is located to sort between
Brantford and Ipswich so
sort of the center of brantford here and
equally you can access hips which along
here and then get to the outer suburbs
of Ipswich again this shows it and
slightly better details so this is the
site here
it's Brantford and then here's its which
so it's just on the sort of boundary of
the district this shows the layout this
here is so the drainage basin would be
for the surface water drainage will be
located in this area this is sort of a
buffer zone which is required to prevent
the site and well to protect the site
from the noise of all the potential
noise from the trains and also to
provide a buffer for the public
right-of-way which is located along here
so it just allows that to remain in the
slightly more raw the seven affordable
dwellings located here and then the
Romania of the dwellings are located
sort of going through here and along
here this just shows the live work units
because the site was previously in
employment at outline stage we did
request a level of employment remained
so and I think that was for live work
units so what they have proposed is that
the outbuildings these five outbuildings
rather than be garages will be retained
for live work while for work use within
a wider sort of live work unit and it's
proposed to take PD mu PD rights from
these buildings so that they can't
become residential without the planning
permission and that they have to be used
first of ancillary employment purposes
they can't be used without outside of
the dwelling so these are the live work
units so I mean the it's well these are
the work part of the live work unit so
these are the outbuildings that we
at the rear they're sort of designed to
be quite multi-purpose so they it does
show sort of and parking at the bottom
and then office up here but equally that
could be used to store at your office or
in various ways
this shows the material plans so you can
just see that some of them are rendered
the ones the blue lines would be
rendered the rest would be brick and
there would be a mix of red and gray
roof tiles these are the affordable
dwellings these are the one-bedroom
flats which they would be just that one
set and then these are the two-bedroom
dwellings okay this is an example of the
four bedrooms dwellings and this is an
example of the five bedroom Wellings the
report does note that there isn't a
great deal of as of mix within the
market dwellings there are all four or
five bedrooms but there is the live work
unit which sort provides another another
use word on the site and this is just
the street scene just showing one set of
the dwellings along here so you can see
they'd be set out like this and
this just shows the refuse collection
points these are sort of details parking
so the the units which have the out
buildings or the garages as live as work
units they've got enough parking outside
for the sort of residential use so they
could pop without using that those units
boundary treatment that would be a
mixture of some walls along here some
brick walls and then some closely
boarded fence sort of on the less
visible and elements of the state of the
site and this just shows some of the
photographs so it is sort of being
derelict for quite a long time now the
previous application was in 2017 and
this there's been nothing on the site so
you can see the derelict structures
again there's more there that just shows
that the nurseries Kostich at the end so
the site would provide access to that
with the affordable x' so just before
that dwelling again this is some more of
the site and then this and so the
recommendation is set out in your report
for approval with the conditions as
proposed thank you
boot opens up to Question Scouts should
we start on a councillor mansard do you
have a Mathison yes thank you yeah I was
wondering do we have the the means of
ensuring somehow rather that the the
live that the work part of the live work
units are not not turning the garages
and home gyms and so forth
yeah the proposal is to take permitted
development rights away from those
outbuildings so they can only be used
for employment purposes in association
with the main dwelling so they can't be
used as a separate employment use so
that that prevents any amenity issues
but that they could they would only be
allowed to be used for employment use
without the requirement for planning
permission so if they wanted to turn
them into a home gym they would have to
come to us and apply for planning for me
Kassem [ __ ] well I was going to ask
about the live work units because I I
recall this application coming at the
outline stage and I was thoroughly
confused by the whole concept of a live
work unit but I think it's now been
cleared up that the live work units are
actually sort of in lieu of garages and
they're not really live work units
because the people are going to live in
the house adjacent to them and work in
the effectively the outbuilding is that
that's am i reading this correctly yeah
that's correct
being further along counts a stringer
did you know caster field thank you I
did point out all county councillor for
this area I didn't know it yes a couple
of points first in power 1 5 can I point
out it's as well as Barry son Edmonds
that Lauren pleads norwich which is our
traffic intensity and there's a question
that goes with that is there any
particular provision in the design of
the dwellings like triple glazed windows
or something to allow them to live with
that level of noise pretty close
and obviously mechanical heat recovery
systems do allow you to keep the windows
closed so is there anything that
recognizes the closeness of the railway
line second thing is the number of
dwellings because it keeps talking about
20 but it says there's 9 full beds and
five five beds so when I was at school
that made 14 and I think there's seven
affordable houses and I'll talk 14 plus
seven comes to 21 so it's just really
know the parish council always has been
somewhat confused that just how many
houses are there not good intercourse or
number and looking through to page 435
it talks about archaeological workers
that program being completed or not
because this is a area that tents
a lot of our ecology so in terms of the
noise from the railway that was
considered to outline stage and they are
providing the buffer and so that the
houses are set away from the railway and
outline stage at was considered to be
acceptable in terms of noise impact in
relation to the number of dwellings
sorry they changed a five to a four very
late on to protect the neighbor so I
think that's why I've got the numbers
wrong is definitely twenty at which
seven are affordable and then in terms
of the archaeology no as far as I'm
aware that hasn't commenced has been
nothing nothing's happened on the site
since 2017 but it is a condition of the
outline thank you keep coming along yep
Casa coffee yes thank you I understand
the work Welling or building and way
would everybody put their mowing
machines bicycles and general de creus
if they don't have a garage I mean the
garret it would be they wouldn't be able
to store equipment within that building
strictly so yes they would have to put a
shed in the garden but I mean the
gardens are reasonable size so you could
fit a garden shed with in there about 40
not withdrawing pd rights for that
purpose then what we do it we're not
preventing withdrawing rights for new
outbuildings we're just saying the
outbuildings that are shown as live work
units or as the work element of the
overall live work would be only be able
to be used for employment purposes yes
sorry to kind of interrupt
can we just be clear then in terms of
accommodation where it says removal of
PD rights on the new work units that's
not a total removal the PD we need to
just clarify that to say only for the
Prevention of domestic use in the work
space
so we are relating purely to the garage
not garish the building that would
otherwise be accorded garage so we only
refer to that removal device is only
with reference to that building itself
can we be that their function slightly
confused and what part of mowing the
lawn isn't live
because it's a live work unit at what
part of mowing the lawn isn't live if
it's a live work unit showing its then
just to work unit okay so essentially
what we're saying here is when you have
a garage we often put a condition on
that says you shall only use it for a
garage and you should not use it for any
other purpose in other words you can't
just stuff all your stuff in there you
have to actually use it for vehicle use
as an active parking space with no
obstruction that's helmet that's how the
condition works or keep empty what we're
trying to say here is this is the same
sort of thing what we're saying we can't
you can't use this for a car you can't
use this for your domestic storage you
have to use this as a workspace so this
building is for a workspace and we would
remove limited development rights
accordingly to ensure that is the use
that this building is for then it's not
a live work unit it's a work unit the if
you add the building together with a
domestic house that would be part of it
would be a live work unit in its
totality so you got a separate building
for working in and you've got a house
that you've got to live in and those are
one unit so there's a live work unit but
it's got to element within that yeah
okay caster go through them cows are
having yes I just wanted to come back on
the explanation that was given regarding
sorry regarding clarity on the PD rights
on the work dwelling only but if you're
going to remove the way your wording it
you've got to be careful are you also
removing the permitted development
rights on the
two amps or you know because they might
want to extend it out the back as well
as put a shed up so I just think you
need to yeah yeah John that was the
clarity I was seeking you my question so
let's be very clear about this condition
we are referring to just the outbuilding
itself and we are restricting it so that
is for work purposes only that we
apologize for the wording of removal of
PD rights it's a bit of a red herring it
is specifically constraining the
building for work purposes and that work
purposes would be an association
ultimately with the house that it would
serve thank you okay cows are having it
just a really sort of basic one on slide
seven this site layout there's some
dotted line I just can't read it even
with my glasses on and see what what
that is what that line is representing
page 79 that door - god I just can't
read what it says yeah that is just
showing where the drainage is so that
they could they have to have a free
meter easement at that point so that's
why there's no development on that area
it's an easement over a drain correct
very cool thank you
well I was going to come back about the
this this business about the PD rights
on the on the live work units and I
think they're actually the work units
but I noticed that in the description of
the work units there is room below to
store a van and you know whilst is it
really impossible that you're gonna stop
somebody putting their bicycle or their
car or their lawnmower in that
downstairs area which is large enough
for about I mean is it an enforceable
condition to impose
ultimately the outline planning
permission included that as part of the
proposal we are basing the reserved
matters therefore on that outline
proposal and we are working what we can
work with in fairness if you ask me the
question is were a policy to support
this there isn't actually a policy we
have in our common local plan for such a
venture so take that as we can take it
okay then no other questions at this
point so we're going to move on so we
don't have anyone from the parish
council we don't have a supporter
objector or the applicant but we do have
an email from councillor James Bascom
unfortunately not be able to make
tomorrow's meeting due to work
commitments please find my comments
below regarding plantation DC 1804 9/5
bypass nurseries Brantford the plan
before you seems to be a reasonable use
of a 1.5 hector's as has previously been
approved by the Planning Committee the
distance of the dwellings from the war
railway line is an important feature as
I believe any closer would cause noise
disruption even with the fence in place
while several mature trees will be
removed in the site under stamp their
size and central location would make it
very difficult to bring them into it
into the design that Beth uses the
available land however I am pleased to
see the orientation allowing for several
of the trees on the border to remain as
a whole I find the design and appearance
of this raposo acceptable for the site
kind regards James cast so members
that's all the information we've had
it's now over to us to discuss debate
and come to a conclusion counselor field
straight off yes I'm gonna say straight
off pacifically is the wood member I was
mauled member recently but that will
wimba approve of this it is a thing that
brings forward a site which has been
derelict for many years it does seem to
me to be quite appropriate housing there
was some slight reservations about the
the railway though under proximity of
the railway line even noticed that some
of the houses are actually orientated so
you can put soda pan
on the roof so it has got some benefits
whether if artistic might grandson or
whatever in in one of these little units
to keep him isolated we would we would
ever come along and enforce the fact
that that doesn't meet the rules I'm not
convinced but never there's nothing
overall on in support of this it seems
to be a good application bringing
derelict land into use so I'll propose
we accept the recommendation of the
office than approve very much Casa
stringer you next yeah yeah I'll be
second during the approval of this
despite the fact that this kind of
design is what Lord even will classify
it as crap I it does show that you can
orientate buildings so the vast majority
of them can face the Sun there's five of
these that don't whereas the majority of
them do face the correct way shows it
can be done just needs a little bit of
imagination I honestly but like the the
live work unit although I think it's the
name of it's interesting I mean if this
would really appeal to someone that like
self-employed nutrition or something
they could store stuff and whatnot would
be great how if they were you know doing
some paperwork upstairs and they decided
to sleep in it how that would then be
enforceable because that's in becoming a
domestic use not business use I already
don't know but frankly it's just a house
with a sort of garden office ready and
store so I'm happy to move approval even
though I say there's a few reservations
about the design but it's it's or what
goes as developing these days position
themselves and speak for themselves and
so I don't think we should yeah so I
think if Lord even isn't here to be able
to answer accusations I think it's got
to be a bit careful counts capsular
heading and you had your hand up is
there one else wish to speak nope happy
to go to vote all those in favor of the
recommendation as laid out in our papers
on page 400
twenty-nine and throw 430 with startup
with the inclusion of the PT rights only
being taken away for the outbuildings
and nowhere else all those in favor of
the recommendation that's unanimous
thank you very much thanks everyone for
today look forward to seeing you all on
Friday when we start all over again
thank you